les français en conflit de mort depuis
plus d'une semaine maintenant un
confinement qui s'est donc durci et des
mesures qui divise de plus en plus les
parisiens
j'ai eu un contrôle ce n'est pas très
agréable ça fait un peu peur peur même
si on a tous les papiers tout ce qu'il
faut et c'est notre liberté qui nous
manque de faire tout ce qu'on veut
surtout avec ce beau temps et j'étais un
peu un peu déçu du fait que que on
savait que coronavirus était là depuis
deux mois et que au lieu d'avoir en fait
une réponse je vous teste jeu la réponse
est je vous contrôler j'ai regardé aussi
le temps qui était accordée aux
aux personnes qui est en prison qui est
de 1h par jour et finalement aujourd'hui
on se retrouve à avoir des mesures qui
nous impose à sortir une heure par jour
dont quelque part on est un peu
prisonnier sas hélas hélas comme par
exemple je peux faire par rapport à les
allées l'état carcéral a plus les jours
passent plus j'ai un petit peu peur de
sortir donc c'est pour ça que je vais
pas trop traîner dans la rue j'ai tout
simplement avant de sortir en général
voient toujours si le boucher n'est pas
n'est pas plein donc là il n'y a pas
beaucoup de monde dont je me dépêche de
me faufiler pour aller le voir et sinon
oui ben après le confinement bas ils le
font c'est nécessaire pour que tout ça
bat disparaît ça s'est assez rapidement
et puis si tout le monde joue le jeu ben
ça sera ça sera positif pour tout le
monde et puis honnêtement je pense qu'à
paris sera le lieu de vie et de fait
quand tout ça tout ça sera à terme sera
terminé on fait les choses qu'on n'a pas
eu le temps de faire quand on était plus
occupé
c'est à dire un peu rangé les placards
veut nettoyer à fond faire ce genre de
choses et puis une partie du temps et
occupé la lecture je suis abonné à
beaucoup de magazines et donc j'ai le
temps de les lire vraiment à fond et
ensuite eh bien on reprend contact avec
des amis qu'on n'a pas le temps de
devoir ou avec lesquels on ne parle pas
trop et tout d'un coup on retrouve une
vie beaucoup plus convivial